[Music]
good morning everyone welcome to our
cloud on-air webinar from Google cloud
we are hosting webinars every Tuesday my
name is Priyanka Ruggerio and today I
will be taking and taking Lisa with us
and talking about machine learning 101
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Googlers on standby
to answer your answer your questions and
during it after so with that let's get
started Lisa over to you hi I'm Lisa
Korra and I'm a machine learning
specialist in the customer engineering
team and hopefully what we'll accomplish
together today is a sense of what
machine learning is what are some of the
decision parameters around it and how
you can make it useful in your business
processes to solve problems and capture
opportunities the first thing we need to
do is establish some terms so artificial
intelligence is the science to make
things smart so I often actually prefer
the term augmented intelligence right
because you're adding a layer of
smartness to things
machine learning is a way of teaching
machines how to solve problems on their
own right you enabling them to learn and
be smart and then deep learning is a
subset of that which is some techniques
to do machine learning now this is the
really important part right is that this
is a new paradigm we've spent decades in
a very controlled way teaching computers
in a very explicit rules with
programming language the new paradigm is
to help the Commission learn from
examples so we're not controlling it
from the top down we're letting patterns
and rules emerge from the data itself so
Lisa this sounds really really simple
when I look at it and this example is it
really that simple um no it's there are
several deep learning approaches that
can get pretty technical um today
because we have such a diverse audience
we're gonna do our best to make sure
that what we're talking about is
accessible to everyone
and is a applicable across industries
right yeah so let's first look at
supervised learning which is probably
the most common thing that people
understand are we gonna get an example
an exciting one I am gonna use one of my
favorite examples because I'm gonna use
training a dog oh yeah because it's
actually not so different for a dog to
learn from a machine to learn and you'll
see why pretty quickly with supervised
learning what you're doing is you're
providing input and output examples so
you're not only providing the input data
but you're also providing the targets
that is associated with that now if you
think about applying that to training a
dog right you help the dog understand
the connection between a command and an
action and when they you make it very
explicit right so you tell them sit and
then when they sit they get a treat so
they make that very explicit connection
between the command and the target
action right and you do that over many
many many examples and you guide them
along the way as they get close to it
you know you give them feedback and you
help them adjust to creating that
outcome right now unsupervised if you
think about our supervised learning you
can probably guess how unsupervised
learning works is you have the data but
you don't provide those labels you don't
provide that target now again think
about how a dog might learn a dog can
learn from observing you they watch you
day in and day out and they observe from
those examples of your behavior and come
to their own ability to predict what
comes next so if I pick up my keys and
the leash he gets excited because he's
able to predict that he gets to come
yeah but if I pick up the keys and I
don't pick up the leash you can see from
the body language that he is predicted
he has to stay home yeah so now we
didn't teach him that that was something
he learned it was unsupervised learning
from observations of data points now
reinforcement learning is a little bit
more like supervised learning except
that the reward is delayed over time so
in reinforcement learning you have a
state you have actions and then you have
a delayed reward so we're going to stick
with training our dog and this time
we're going to train our dog on a full
obstacle course
instead of a single
and so as the dog is running through and
having a point of being a state at any
point in time along the obstacle course
we provide verbal feedback for either
doing the next action being a legal
action or an illegal action along the
course and we guide them with that
verbal feedback until they get to the
win at the end when they get that reward
so reinforcement learning is feedback
guided along the way until you get to
the successful outcome but that
successful outcome is delayed a bit okay
now we use machine learning in
everything we do sundar calls us an AI
first company and what he means by that
is that we try to use machine learning
in every possible way to enhance our
customer experiences and make our
products better and so if we think about
some of the techniques that we just
talked about and how they might show up
in some of our products
let's take Google photos with that the
supervised door unsupervised do you
think supervised because it's not labels
exactly right when you upload your image
and we automatically suggest labels for
you that's because we trained it on a
data set of hundreds of millions of
images with The Associated labels and so
that's able to be able to I think
there's what 20,000 labels that we
associated with that so it's able to
make your life easier by having the
Machine take on that load now gmail
smart reply what do you think supervised
or unsupervised that is unsupervised
because there must be a large amount of
data that it's looking at and then not
just data from my emails and my replies
but also from all the other emails and
replies and then and then identifying
what are the different one of the
patterns on for the reply so I would say
unsupervised exactly right it's
identifying patterns from massive
amounts of data because trying to come
up with the input-output examples for
every possible permutation of language
would be really hard so that's a great
example of using unsupervised learning
and then everyone's pretty aware of the
big alphago win
against Lisa Dole with a global champion
and NGO and the alphago won four out of
five games and it did that by paying
hundreds of millions of games and
getting feedback along that process but
we don't just use it in our own products
right hmm but we use these models
together right so one input is often the
output to another model because a model
solves one problem really well but most
business processes have multiple tasks
along the way right so you have to have
models work together and here's a great
example of the vision API being used to
capture the text from an image and then
passing that to another model with the
translate API to convert that text to
another language I just had a question
can you combine like in this case we're
combining two moderns together but how
many of these models can you actually
combine together is there a limit on
this the limit wouldn't be from a
machine learning perspective the limit
would actually probably be more from
your infrastructure perspective right so
the networking or the compute power
behind it to pass those inputs and
outputs along the process so how long
would that chain be right so if you
needed fast latency then you'd probably
have to limit the number of models that
you use but that's not a machine
learning question that's more of an
infrastructure question so you just have
to think through your business process
and think which tasks can the machine
enhance along the way but we're also
using machine learning to help other
people do amazing things it's not just
about products and services it's also
about trying to use machine learning to
make things better for people yeah so
this one's actually really close to my
heart because I'm from India and I have
seen a lot of rural places in India that
do not have access to doctors or say
good doctors but what but what Google
brain has done is they've built this
software based on machine learning and
there's this model that identifies when
you feed a retina scans to this model it
identifies a disease that needs two
diabetes
and and that eventually leads to you
know people not being able to see so
that is pretty huge so this model can
take these retina scans and identify
whether somebody has that disease or has
indicators of that disease and then at
that point it I tell ste or alerts this
person to actually go see a doctor and
to me that is that is HUGE now I can
look into my phone and and just identify
that I might have a problem and I should
go see a doctor is is huge when I don't
have a doctor around me and somebody's
telling me I should go do that dad to me
is huge
it is I mean you know if I had my
eyesight saved by looking into a phone
camera I think I would feel it's pretty
magical right right and that's the big
myth of machine learning that it's magic
and I hate to disillusion you because
we'd all like to believe in magic but
it's just math it's just linear algebra
and calculus combined to transform
inputs into outputs and here's another
really key concept we want you to walk
away from today that machine learning is
the process of algorithmically finding
patterns in data and we're going to keep
that word patterns is going to keep
coming up and we're going to keep coming
back to the data because I want you to
think about the data as the knowledge
potential of what your machine can learn
the the concept of machine learning has
been around for a long time and the
concept in general for deep learning I
think has existed since like 1960s yes
so what if the questions I had and I'm
pretty sure from the audience as well is
why is it that it's so important now and
why is it that people are working
towards it now much more and are getting
excited about this much more now versus
like in the past well there's three key
enablers okay that are making all the
difference now because you're absolutely
right the a lot of this isn't new now
we're doing new things now and we're
pushing the boundaries of knowledge
all the time but one of the biggest
factors is the data right I ninety
percent of the world's data was
generated in the last two years right
and it's coming from everywhere right
it's structured it's unstructured it's
coming from the web it's coming from
social media it's coming from ERP
systems and CRM systems and it's coming
from Internet of Things and machine
sensors and phones and just a million of
different options for bringing the data
into your world and representing human
reality via data points now a lot of
that data just sits there passive now
right we're not doing enough with it
because it might be in some format that
we don't know how to work with but you
can transform that and start pulling
insights and predictive capabilities out
of that data set but if you didn't have
these giant things to learn from enough
examples to learn from we wouldn't be
able to build these great models and the
other aspect of course is the computing
power right them you can't work with
that much data and these different
models without the compute power in 1961
when the multi-layer perceptron was
originally discovered the super cube
theater at the time you know didn't even
hold a candle to your phone today so it
couldn't do anything with that knowledge
we couldn't explore it enough right yeah
so now we can but of course what does it
start with data data it's not who that
has the best algorithm who wins it's who
has the most data and that's coming from
a co-founder of Google brain and a
former Stanford professor now why do we
agree with him why do we think that
that's so true right the data determines
what the model will learn remember that
it's the knowledge potential right if
the data does not accurately completely
and fairly represent the problem
environment a model cannot find the
optimal solution now when we talk about
completeness what are some of the things
that come into that variety right so you
can't just train it on examples of a
user behaving in one way or just a
single user right you need a variety of
users and you need those users to behave
in a
of ways so diversity of your data set is
really important and then of course
number so that's the complete part is
that we need to make sure that you have
a lot of it now the second part is the
quality of the models
so yes the ideas have been around
forever but without the ability to test
those ideas against large data sets and
with a lot of compute power they
couldn't identify the best techniques
right and now we can write so let's um
start to drill into how models work and
we're gonna try to to keep this at a
good level are we gonna go into math and
formulas and stuff a little bit okay
little bit so fun parts coming but the
important thing again conceptually right
conceptually we're applying weights to
features to calculate an output right so
if we think about how a human makes
decisions creates an output we also do
it by applying weights to features all
right let's think about looking for an
apartment right and how much weight do
you apply to the parking space right how
much do you apply to the location right
these are features of the apartment that
you then apply different values to in
order to predict which one will satisfy
your need same idea with machines now
the difference of course is that
machines only work with numeric data
Yeah right so we have to convert any of
our data points into numbers to work
with
so if we have an image this one is from
the CFR ten data set so it's um you know
very common data set used to test out
models so you can compare models across
different architectures so you take the
image and you convert it to an array of
the 32 width by 32 height by the three
channels red green blue okay right and
you end up with three thousand seventy
two numbers in total each of those
numbers representing that pixel feature
alright so that becomes the X in the
function the input data and then we have
these weights that we start to assign to
each of those pixels to understand its
salience
how important is that feature to
calculating the output and in the end
you end up with the ten different labels
that are in that data set and you're
able to identify that that's a cat
awesome so let's think again about this
neural network right we have the concept
of the input and the weight and we start
to do a matrix multiplication key term
that we're going to come back to later
when we talk about the power of hardware
because matrix multiplications are
compute intensive but we have our input
and then we assign our weights that's a
product and then we add them together
across the different weighted features
to come up with an output we run that
output through an activation function
think of the activation function as
being a sorting mechanism right so
you're sort of sorting signal from noise
yeah which of these features contributes
the most to determining the output right
and once we have that then we do a
prediction so we calculate our first
guest now remember that we start out
knowing nothing so we randomly
initialize the weights because we don't
know anything okay and then we make our
first prediction which is probably
pretty awful we compare it with the
label and that error that difference is
what we use to guide how we're going to
update the weight how we're going to
adjust it yeah right and then we keep
doing that iteratively across all of
these learning runs all of these
different examples until we have finally
adjusted that weight to the point where
it's a very accurate representation of
the knowledge potential and the reality
that we're trying to capture to solve
the problem or capture the opportunity
now here is a supervised learning
problem a simple binary classification
for vision but this is the deep part
right so now you have your neural
network you have your weighted outputs
right the first layer is just capturing
very simple concepts like maybe shading
right you then pass that to the next
layer so the outputs of one layer
becomes the inputs to the next and that
next one refines the concepts and turns
those shading into like lines or shapes
and then it keeps doing that along the
way so that the lines and shapes become
eyes
mouths and then the eyes and the mouth
and the ears become cats versus dogs and
then finally you have that output
understanding the classification and
capturing the label yeah that makes
sense it does it does I think it'll be
good to go and visualize this a little
bit for people right yeah okay so let's
see an example so that you can start to
see that connection between data and
output so we've chosen this example
today mainly to guide us through the
process of how machine learning actually
works and how a machine actually
actually takes the inputs gets trained
evaluates and then and then predicts and
I think Auto ml vision is a great
example because it helps you visualize
there are images that are going into the
systems it helps you learn and
understand what is actually happening so
that's the sole purpose of taking this
as an example and we're going to
consider ourselves to be people who are
learning about clouds to understand the
weather patterns so let's consider
ourselves as scientists and in
identifying weather patterns I have
taken some examples here of images of
different clouds and they are ITER and
they're also labeled with different
labels of the types of clouds now when
you hop into Auto ml vision interface
the first thing you see is is the images
which is obviously Lisa has emphasized
enough about the fact that data is
really important so you'll never
emphasize that enough ever so we go with
this as soon as we enter into the
interface we end up putting data in and
in this case it's the images of the
clouds now there are two ways to get
entered data in one is through Google
Cloud storage you could create a CSV of
your links to all the images associated
with the labels and once you have those
you could upload that CSV into the
interface and you would have all these
images loaded up in here the other way
to upload images is to just click on
this ad
button and just use the user interface
to actually upload those images so those
are the two ways to get to get your data
into the system once you have the images
in you'll also be able to filter and see
the number of images in here I think
this is important if you see we have
large number of images for cumulus and
serious in and also also I can't even
read it so I'm just gonna avoid it not
reading so the last three we have a
large number of those and then and you
can see the ones with the outros are a
little bit less and we'll come back to
this that's why I'm pointing this out so
you have this data set now once you have
the data set you have the next step
which is to train your model using this
data when we hit the we've already
obviously trained this model so we're
not gonna do that today but when you do
it for yourself with your own image data
set you will be able to use the Train
tap to train your model and then you
could I you could use options to train
it for a longer period of time or less a
period of time and there are advantages
to training longer because the model
would learn better is there anything
else you'd like to add inside yeah no I
think that's the key point in the
compute time is that this is also
remember compute hours it's not
necessarily linear time so the two
models that we've trained you can see
one has a one-hour compute time but I
believe that was probably about 10
minutes and I think that the second
model even though it says to compute
hours because of distributed processing
and parallel computing that I think was
only about 15 minutes okay yeah so make
sure you select the time depending on
how good you want the model to be and
how well trained you want it to be so
after the first two steps of getting the
data in training the model now we are at
the evaluate step which is where you
you're actually able to see the metrics
and how do you see the metrics there are
multiple different metrics that you can
see but the one that I like to highlight
and point out is the confusion matrix
now it's not confusing it's really just
that you would understand why it's
called confusion matrix in just a little
bit so when you let's take a step back
before we dive into confusion matrix
when you add images in to cloud Auto ml
vision what it does is it separates out
your images into training data set in
test dataset and it tests that
automatically which is great yes so you
don't have to do any of that
you just upload and it'll take care of
the separating for you and for machine
machine learning for your model to train
on a specific data set and then it's
important that you have a certain test
data set ready to train the model that
the model has never seen before exactly
and what we're doing here this confusion
matrix is is taking that test data set
and then and then predicting and then
showing you how accurate that
predictions were so in this case we can
see that it was 90% 94.7 0.7% accurate
for the first two of them but then we
see a less accuracy on the ultra Stratus
one which is 46.2%
now you also see that 23% of those were
identified as cirrus so this could and
now this allows us to actually go into
our data set and see what the problem
might be right and goes back to Lisa's
earlier point it depends on how good
your data is and how much data you have
supplied to the model so if you remember
when we were looking at the images and
their labels
the ones with Altos were very less so we
had very few examples of those in there
so that's why our models probably
getting confused so we may need more
data for to support those support those
examples and
I think that is that is the important
point that we wanted to come across that
data is obviously the key you want to
make sure that whatever you want the
Machine where your model to learn you've
provided enough examples of that in in
the data set for it to learn from yes
right and then the last step is
obviously prediction and we provide you
you can see here the the current command
for the REST API we provide ml vision
would generate a REST API for you that
you could use to to apply into your
debate this model for predictions into
your either your website or your mobile
application whatever it is that that you
want to use this model into hopefully
that was a good starting point in terms
of seeing how the whole all the steps
work from putting the data into training
to evaluate and then starting to predict
with that I'll pass it over to Lisa to
give us some more information on models
yes I mean I think the important point
that we wanted with that was this
connection between data and quality yep
now parameters are what the model learns
to use to represent that knowledge
potential hyper parameters guide how
well or how poorly the model learns
hyper parameters Lisa has always been
something that I have struggled to
understand so if we can take some
examples to to help our audience learn
this yeah hyper parameters I've always
thought they should have come up with a
better term right because it is a little
confusing the what versus the hell yeah
but a couple of my favorites are
learning rate so the learning rate
controls how much you adjust that weight
during each learning iteration so as
you're going through the examples how
much do you change that weight up or
down to reflect the new information you
got from the latest example right the
latest error signal that guided how you
changed it the learning rate says how
much you change it yeah right so I want
you to imagine that you have a huge
stack of books to get through to learn
something now you could just skim
through them very quickly and get to the
end yeah but you'd probably miss
something
and you'd certainly miss the optimal
solution or you could go very slowly
line by line take notes on each one but
then you might only get through a third
or half of the books in the time allowed
so you would never get to a solution you
need to find the right learning rate for
yourself as you go through those books
the model needs the right learning rate
to understand how fast or how slow to
adjust those weights if the adjustment
is too big then it could jump right over
the optimal weight but if it's too small
it could take too long and never
converge because it'll just run out of
compute time so the learning rate is
really important another one that I like
is the dropout rate and I like that
because it seems counterintuitive but
it's actually really in sync with how
humans learn so the dropout rate is
intended to prevent something called
overfitting okay a model that over fits
to the data set is a model that has
memorized data so it can't actually
predict anything new it would totally
fail on that test set right there's
something that's never seen it fails
right so we introduced a dropout rate to
basically make the learning harder
periodically we randomly zero out some
weights just like a human leg just like
how I forget where after I read
something and like ten days in I need to
go back and read it exactly right but
then you retain it more if you have this
interspace learning right well this
works the same way right so dropout rate
is another really important hyper
parameter that can impact the quality of
your model so hyper parameters are the
how and the different combinations
really make a difference in terms of
data science productivity now the
automation that we saw AI is created by
a model so it's a model creating a model
and that's neural architecture search
net and you'll notice that it's not only
more accurate than the human models and
these were created by some of the finest
mind in the AI community you know you've
got the best of Google and the best of
Facebook creating these kind of things
and you'll notice that the machine won't
beat them and not only did it beat them
in accuracy which is the quality of the
model but also the operations so the
amount of compute time it took and the
parameters it's smaller so it'll be able
to be served faster so it's not only
more accurate but it's more efficient
they
the last part of the why now that we
want to cover is the compute power right
so the ideas aren't new the data that
we've been getting for a few years but
it's this ability to process massive
amounts of data with big complex models
and a variety of hyper parameter
combinations that needs this kind of
compute Tyler power right yeah and these
models can be really large these
datasets can be so large it can
literally take months to process those
big datasets through the big models and
to optimize the hyper parameters along
the way so for a data for a data
scientist to wait months for a result is
a huge productivity impact right yeah so
if we could experiment faster then we
could create higher quality models right
and the more compute power we have the
more we can distribute the training and
the more we can optimize each training
session to get that quick iteration and
more experiments that we can run so
hardware accelerators basically help us
do the training faster exactly right
because they're optimized for that right
so here is training a large-scale
machine translation model and you can
just imagine the size of that model
language is so complex the knowledge
potential that a machine would have to
capture would be gigantic yeah and in
this case you know would be 24 hours
being parallel processed across 32 GPUs
but because tensor processing units
optimize that matrix multiplication we
saw earlier and it's really specialized
for deep learning and for the math that
is unique to deep learning you can
compress that to an hour and a half so
imagine a data scientist waiting 24
hours to get the results of an
experiment and make another adjustment
or an hour and a half yeah it was big
productivity increase now I think we
have learned the model and the wave
models work and the math behind it a
little bit but I think it'll be good for
us to understand what are the things to
keep in mind as as people start to think
about machine learning and apply
into their projects well the first thing
is that the model is really it's the
most fun piece but it's a small piece of
the overall solution data data data so
data collection data management data
understanding with exploration analysis
and different feature engineering to
make sure that your data is accurately
capturing either the problem that you
want to solve or the opportunity you
want to capture you need to represent it
in the data and that's going to take a
huge amount of effort the model then is
a pretty small part of it but what's
important is once you have that model
you want to use it in your business
process so that's called serving the
model creating the predictions and you
want to make sure that you're retraining
it periodically so you need to monitor
it for its accuracy because it can
degrade over time if the reality that
you're capturing is actually changing
right so all of these are pieces that
you have to think about when you're
wanting to use machine learning in your
business process now some things to
consider our please start simple and
then add complexity only as needed so
try some of the pre-existing models like
cloud III api's and if that's not
getting you what you need then try an
auto ml service where you can make your
more domain-specific by tailoring it
with your own data set if that's not
getting what you need you can try
something called transfer learning where
you learn from another model to
jumpstart your own custom model and then
finally build a custom model with a
custom data set but that will of course
take the highest skills level and the
most amount of time so you want to do
that
only when it adds real competitive
differentiation for you see what you can
do with what's already available first
yep now analyze your data to ensure
you're accurately and fairly
representing the reality you want to be
learned the data is your knowledge
potential so make sure you focus on
getting that right and then make sure
the data features you use to train the
model are available when you want to use
the model so when we talk about
accurately representing environment
let's think about predictive maintenance
for a moment when you might have machine
sensors in the field but they're really
impacted by the weather so you want to
use weather data to help make your model
smarter you want to increase that
knowledge potential so you use a weather
data set to train your model along with
the sensor data but at the time of
prediction
well you have that weather data
available right you need to make sure
that what you train is also what you
have when you want to predict right next
steps there's so much more to learn and
I really recommend starting with the
machine learning crash course that we
have on our site
we've also collaborated with Coursera to
create data engineering and machine
learning classes there are tons of
tutorials available on the Google cloud
platform and as always there's Google
search for any topics or white papers
that you might be interested in I hope
we've piqued your interest on some
things today and then if you already
have something going on or on machine
learning that you would like some help
with from our teams then we do have
Google cloud account teams that are
available to help you with any of your
projects so reach out to them and then
once you reach out to them if you're if
you do require professional services and
we have very high quality partners that
can partner with you on your project as
well so we can bring them in and our
professional services in as as needed
for your projects so make use of these
resources and let us know what you're
doing in machine learning all right so
we're going to switch to questions now
and we'll be back in less than a minute
you
all right everyone looks like we have a
bunch of questions from the live
audience so we'll ask those one by one
and have Lisa answer them the first one
here is Deena seems to be very critical
to machine learning how and where do I
get enough data to build an accurate
model well first of all thank you for
listening
and how and where you can get enough
data to build an accurate model is
complex because it depends on your
particular situation and what problem
you're trying to solve but one thing I
would say is you don't have to just look
inside your own organization to find
data don't forget that you can enrich
your data set with other external
options right so there's some big query
public data sets yeah and Explorer yeah
right - see those are also great for
prototyping and exploring different
model options while you're gathering
your data inside the enterprise because
sometimes it can take quite a while to
put those data sets together and it
might be different people working on the
data and the model so if the model folks
can be testing with some public data
sets while the data folks are getting
all of that collected right so I would
look at big query public data sets
Cagle has a lot of open datasets
academics are often sharing their work
and publishing not only the model code
that they do but the datasets they use
to train that code so those are options
outside of the enterprise and then
inside the enterprise just think about
the problem you're trying to solve and
what do you believe most accurately and
completely represents that problem ok
that's that's where you helpful so the
second question here is can I still
build a good machine learning model with
a small amount of data again it depends
the things that I constant repeat are
patterns and data and it depends but I
you can use transfer learning because
transfer learning enables you to use a
sort of jumpstart model that has already
been trained on a massive data set and
then you can customize it with a small
amount of data so when we think about
the example that Priyanka showed us with
Auto well vision that was a tiny data
set there
1800 examples right really small which
normally we would say no way can kind of
machine learn from so few examples but
because it uses the NASA net
architecture in the background and a
trained model from that Nazz net its
able to just tailor the last few layers
of the model to customize it for your
domain specificity so if you only have a
small amount of data then you need to
start looking at transfer learning
options so the key to this is going back
to some of the things to consider points
that you made start from what's already
available then look at Auto ml maybe and
then start to look at transfer learning
and then if none of those do the job
that you're looking to do then you build
your own custom model exactly and
there's things that you can do to expand
that data data augmentation options but
again you know bigger is better when it
comes to the data part which saves us to
the second question
there's last question is bigger always
better romano's well there's a trade-off
between speed and accuracy so it depends
on how you define better what is it that
you want to optimize for if you want to
optimize for accuracy then it can be
that bigger is better but remember that
concept we talked about overfitting
right overfitting means that it can
memorize if your model is too big and
complex it might just memorize things
and not be able to generalize right so
Tom sometimes you need that sort of a
little bit of error in the mix right and
then the other thing you need to think
about is not just accuracy but speed the
bigger the model then the slower it will
create the inference and if latency is
an issue when you're using that in your
business process then a smaller model
might indeed be much better even if you
do sacrifice some accuracy okay well
that's amazing
thank you so much everybody for
listening stay tuned for the next
session
bring your teams closer together with G
Suites meeting solutions and thank you
you
you